[Music]
Vince I have that quarterly analysis
that you asked for
I had a quarter of these nuts on your
chin right it's just that I wanted to
review some of these numbers with you it
seems like our earnings are low against
our original projections these nuts were
low against your chin
you know Vince if you ever need to talk
to me about something I'm more than
happy to listen these nuts would be more
than happy to rest against your chin
Hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kinda funny
at first these nuts were kind of funny
against your chin Vincente worried about
you
I was worried about these nuts on your
chin man seriously these nuts are
seriously on your chin mr. Graham
I just got a call from st. Mary's
Hospital and your parents were in a
serious car accident I'm so sorry
but your mother is dead and your father
is on life support
[Music]
these nuts were supporting life on your
chin sorry amber Vince you got to stop
it your mother just passed away there's
nothing to what you can't no they didn't
they didn't Vince listen you got to
leave here right now then go be with
your dad this could be the last time
that you get to see you this be the last
time I get to see my nuts on your god
damn it Vincent your father might be
dying these nuts might be dying on your
chin god damn it Fitz snap the [ __ ] out
of it
your mother is dead okay
it worked in every situation and I know
I know
it wasn't that funny
it really wasn't bad fun events
really
I would not go so far as to say it was
really funny Vince
but it wasn't though
it was
it was
like we disagree it's funny okay one
more time there's gonna be one record
saying it wasn't really that funny
[Music]
wasn't that funny
[Music]
stay with me then I love you I love
these nuts on your chin
[Music]
you